uh
well welcome to full council meeting on
the 29th of november
uh just to say now we're back in the
chamber just to remind you that um if
you are going to speak then please be
standing to make
your comments
so item one we have apologies for
absence
from counselors
hill
holmes
jones lilly
morley
ridgeway and stone are there any other
apologies
councillor dale
thank you chair uh just council remnants
to add to that please thank you any
other apologies
if not item two declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests and or
other interests not already on their
register of interest in any items on the
agenda and withdraw from the meeting at
the appropriate time
are there any
[Music]
councillor liggett
like to declare an interest in item 7
and 15.
thank you
any other decorations
item three minutes of the last meeting
um there are
two councils who were present who
haven't been recorded as being present
at the october meeting and they are
councillors lacey and councillor
stratford stevenson
so they need to be amended and added to
the list of attendees
other than that can we move please to
approve that they are a true and
accurate record counselor
birkin
i'd like to make a comment about the the
fact that this last meeting that i had
was very poor audibly for several of our
colleagues notably my colleague jeff
councillor jeff lilly has asked me to
speak about this and i know there are
other people who have difficulties um
it's not particularly marked in the
minutes and i'm not sure how we could be
specifically multi in the minutes but i
think it does need noting hopefully as
part of this meeting that uh the um
sound quality was very very poor and
that's made i think that's one of the
reasons that some of the people have not
turned up today let's make it even more
difficult to to get on with these
natures and
to process them and get involved in them
properly thank you chair
thank you council birkin they those
comments were made at the meeting i know
we don't take verbatim minutes but
because of the the nature of hell
um
it could have affected people's ability
to be included in the discussions and so
on i think perhaps there should be a
record that those comments were made by
council lilly in particular
and so with your agreement can those be
added to the minutes please
thank you so if we could move to
approving and please counsel dale
yeah happy to move uh chair
a second to please
thank you council cupid all those in
favor
anyone against
any abstentions
i have one opposition thank you and
those are carried
item 4 chairman's announcements
since the last meeting of full council
the consort and i have represented the
district at a number of events
these include the high sheriff of
derbyshire's legal service at derby
cathedral
the
769th elkeston chart affair
voluntary sector awards
and the unveiling of a memorial for
animals in war at home rook valley park
we laid a wreath at mill rain on
remembrance day in a service laid back
led by the civic chaplain
which was well supported by members and
staff
we also attended a service in northeast
derbyshire in remembrance sunday and
laid a wreath on behalf of the district
we are looking forward to attending
forthcoming festive events
such as three carol services two
christmas concerts
and a partridge in a pear tree
work has commenced on developing the
action plan for partnership with
darmstadt dieberg and correspondents
undertaken with the land rat
we've also progressed plans for her
majesty's platinum jubilee
this includes action for the queen's
canopy
the first tree is being planted
officially tomorrow afternoon
consideration has been given to the
district community event planned for the
4th of june
and a mast choirs event on the 5th of
june
a district civic civic service is booked
for the 22nd of may
and designs for a legacy item being
initiated
we have been asked to align our district
celebrations with those planned by her
majesty's lord lieutenant in the county
i am grateful to the parish councils who
have responded positively to my request
for donations to my appeal for ashke
hospice
although everyone recognises the
financial pressures on local government
it is acknowledged that the hospice
makes a significant difference in
northeast derbyshire
i wish to thank the following councils
for their generosity
barlow
brampton
kaylo
eckington
grassmore
horrymore side and walton
morton
north wingfield
sutton conductmanton
unstone and westington
i understand the further two councils
have pledged a donation
i'm grateful to colleagues and staff who
have supported fundraising events such
as a peak performance concert
quiz night
and a successful christmas fair at the
technique stadium yesterday
i hope many of you will join with us at
the christmas concert at st john's
church from half past seven in the
evening
on the 10th of december
your support makes a difference
thank you
item 5 then leaders announcements over
to you council dale
thank you chair
i think i speak for all of us in
highlighting the concern around the new
covid varian omicron
clearly it's important that we remain
calm but it's vital that we all consider
at this time of year in particular what
extra precautions we can take to keep
ourselves and our loved ones safe
wearing masks where appropriate regular
hand washing and being mindful of
testing ourselves on a regular basis
aside from the new variant
code rates in north east derbyshire and
in particular in
clay cross
grasmore and the homewood areas are
fairly high at the moment and while our
vaccination rates are also among the
highest in the county and the counties
among the highest in the country the
same three areas i've described there so
clay cross grasmore and homewood
are notably a few percentage points
behind the rest of the district in terms
of vaccination rates which may help to
explain those higher rates of
transmission i therefore urge all
residents to get vaccinated if not
already and take up the opportunity for
a booster job jab at the appropriate
time particularly those residents in
clay cross grassmoor and homewood as
i've discussed
moving on to some good news you may have
already been aware that our
environmental health department have
recently seized and crushed a ford
transit van that had been involved in
the flight tipping of some waste
i know that some opposition councillors
here today have been so eager to claim
credit for this that they practically
have you believe they were driving the
digger themselves
but its actions not words that count so
i want to pay particular tribute to our
environmental health officers who worked
extremely hard to make this happen
i sincerely hope that it acts as a
deterrent to anyone thinking about
fly-tipping in our beautiful district
and i know cabinet and officers are
working hard on further deterrent
measures
members will be aware that work is
progressing very well on the carbon
reduction inspired renovation of
eggington swimming falls and solar
panels have recently been installed on
the roof
we're still hopeful of reopening in time
for christmas
at killer marsh the final contract has
now been signed and the contract has
officially started on site
i want to thank the officers from across
the various teams within the council
including the leisure service legal
states we're working so hard to make
this happen and i think it's great
evidence of a one-team approach in
action
following on from the success at
eckington we've also submitted an
application for a similar government
grant to help decarbonize dromfield's
support centre if successful the project
will include the use of heat pump
technologies solar panels on the roof
and efficiencies within the plant room
it could save at least 193 tons of
carbon emissions per year the equivalent
of taking 77 houses off the grid
keeping with the subject of climate
change by carrying out improvements like
those to our leisure centre by
insulating around 400 homes in the
district we've managed to remove
892 tons of co2 equivalent to removing
nearly 200
cars from the road
permanently
we've also recently relaunched our
community action grants and eco schools
grant scheme and i'd urge local
community groups and schools to visit
our website to find out more about how
to apply
businesses can also apply for support
and grants of up to ten thousand pounds
with the vision derbyshire business
support scheme
on the subject of vision derbyshire
i've continued to attend the leaders
meetings and progress has been made
towards the formalization of the working
arrangements i will therefore bring a
more detailed update to the next meeting
so council can consider the issues in
full but in the meantime this council
remains at the table to discuss the
potential benefits but hasn't formally
signed up to anything as previously
agreed
members will also more than likely be
aware of the government's announcement
of county deals earlier this summer
while the details are fairly scammed at
this stage with more expected in the
forthcoming white paper the government
has been clear that they will consider
any models of governance for the deal
and that it is clearly very clearly not
a vehicle for unitarization as some have
claimed the havoc county council is
working with derby city council as the
two operator authorities who would hold
responsibility and accountability for
any deal to seek out a county deal from
the government but they've been very
clear that this will be in collaboration
with the district councils based on the
vision derbyshire model again i'll bring
a more comprehensive update on the
situation at the next full council
on behalf of our member development
working group i also just want to remind
all members that you will now have
received an email asking you to complete
a short questionnaire the purpose is for
the member development working group to
carry out a training needs analysis
what you tell the group in your answers
will help shape the training and
development program for counsellors
right the way through to may 2023
there are three quick uh three
key questions that i would like to ask
you to answer
these are about what training you've had
so far what was good and bad about it
and going forward what sort of training
and on what topics would help you now
the working group wants to progress this
quite quickly
and therefore they have a tight deadline
of the 20th of december so i'd ask that
all members please try and complete the
questionnaires and return them to
governance by then and hopefully that
will make enable the working group to
make some real progress on training that
will benefit all of us and also benefit
the people that we represent and finally
i just want to congratulate you chair on
your recent election as chair of the
north derbyshire magistrates bench it's
a fantastic achievement very well done
to you thank you
thank you i just let the applause die
down
[Laughter]
thank you
too late too
so um thank you item six public
participation no questions have been
submitted under procedure rule number
eight for this meeting so item seven
is the independent remuneration panel so
over to the assistant director of
governance and monitoring officer please
thank you chair the council is required
to have an independent remuneration
panel look at its members allowances
scheme every four years or so
in addition the irp will be asked to
consider whether there should be a
special responsibility allowance for the
chair of licensing
the council does not have a standing irp
or independent remuneration panel
the members have generally been from
other public sectors and have been
unpaid for their work
in february this year following a
standards committee report unsuccessful
efforts were made to appoint members to
this panel
as these ones successful he's now
proposed that each panel member will be
paid 200 pounds for a full review of the
members allowances scheme at the council
including the sra for the chair of
licensing
in addition it's proposed that a
permanent head of paid service
delegation is given to ensure that the
panel can be set up in a timely way
happy to answer any question the
recommendations are on page 17.
thank you thank you are there any
comments or questions
if not we moved to recommendations
please a proposal
thank you council dale and seconded by
council cupid so it's been moved and
seconded all those in favor
all those against
any abstentions
i hope that's carried thank you so item
a treasury management update hope you
please counsel parking
thank you chair
this report uh is an update on the
council's treasury management activities
for april
uh to september and this year for
council to note so april to september
2021
appendix one details the current
borrowing activity and the interest paid
on external borrowing
as well as providing an update on the
council's investments and interests
these generate
as council to
note this report
and uh i'll move it unless there's any
questions
any comments or questions
it's been moved do you have a second to
please thank you council dale
all those in favor
any against
any abstentions
let's carry it thank you
item nine then the northeast derbyshire
local plan for 2014 to 2034.
hope of jupiter's council cupid
thank you chair um so we hopefully all
recognize that planning and setting a
development plan is one of the most
important things for our district
particularly given recent or indeed not
so recent history
a local plan allows us to decide which
areas should be used for housing or
business to plan infrastructure and
gives greater protection to the areas we
want to keep as green fields or spaces
planning is always difficult and often a
compromise and since becoming your
planning cabinet member over the last
couple of years and as an administration
we've always tried to be open accessible
and transparent to residents and
communities even if it's not the result
we want to hear i have to be really
honest that whatever happens today we
can't completely fix this
as cabinet member tabling this report
and having worked to try to improve the
issues within it extensively i want to
set the record straight on what we've
been doing and set out where we find
ourselves the facts the risks and the
choice that we all have to make today
and then as a local councillor and ward
member i want to set out my views and
rationale from that perspective as again
that's something we all have to consider
as a new administration we inherited a
plan a decade in the making
which had taken so long it led to the
threat of government intervention
we've had a perfect storm of thousands
of houses approved most notably in the
south but also actually across the
district by speculative development and
a lack of infrastructure planning
associated with this
we also inherited greenbelt allocations
in the north of the district despite the
persistence and success of residents
community groups and my conservative
colleagues to reduce that from several
thousand homes allocated in the
greenbelt at the start to a remaining
1275 greenbelt allocations on submission
and now to less than half that and the
four sites in the plan as it stands
a very difficult situation but some
progress nonetheless
on taking control of the council we
paused the plan as we promised to do to
review the housing numbers and try to
remove the remaining greenbelt
allocations
over the following months there was a
significant amount amount of work done
to review the situation
given that the plan was under
examination and so part of a formal
legal process and that an interim report
and judgment had been received
this led to correspondence with the
independent inspector to see what
options she would or wouldn't allow what
came back in summary was two options and
they were really only two
continue to make modifications and tried
to seek further changes from an
inspector who was already allowing the
removal of two green belt sites or
withdraw the plan from examination and
start again by choice or eventually by a
slow default
i have to be clear to residents and
members amending was and is not an
option it's not about just substituting
sites as there's a strategy that
underpins it an evidence base that sits
behind any plan
so amending at the stage we inherited is
like a perilously stacked house of cards
to take the nearby example of sheffield
apologies to them you pull just one
brick out and the whole plan falls and
you go right back to the start it's all
interconnected we have a duty to work
with other councils and organizations
the evidence documents are interlinked
for instance if you try to switch
allocated sites or suggest a new
settlement that would represent a
material change in the evidence base and
a change in the plan strategy
that's then not compatible with the rest
of the plan or with the documents that
underpin it such as economic employment
population data schlas housing capacity
forecasts could go on
and they all relate to one another so if
you change one you then have to reassess
them all
this cannot be done quickly other
councils trying to accelerate new plans
are being told and proving it will take
at least three to four years as there
are statutory milestones or perhaps
millstones on looking at all the options
i want to reassure the chamber and
residents we did carefully consider them
we sought legal advice from some of the
most experienced barristers including qc
and planning experts in the country we
spoke to ministers and mhclg as it then
was we spoke to paz the planning
advisory service and even spoke to one
of the heads of the planning
inspectorate and every single one came
to the same conclusion
amending the evidence base would not be
possible within the current examination
and would lead to the withdrawal of the
plan
this means the choice was clear
continue to make modifications to
maintain the current weight of the plant
and to properly get the eckington and
coal aston greenbelt sites out and i
really have to emphasise that those two
green belt sites were not out of the
plan when we inherited it
and asked the inspector to extend this
further through that same logic or
withdraw the plan
to move on to the option of starting
again i've covered the issue of the time
it would take but the most compelling
concern for me is that we would have to
reset the clock
that means the speculative development
and allocations that have been built out
over the last seven years would no
longer count towards our target
with the result that we would have to
find sites for an additional two
thousand houses for a new plan period
also whilst losing greenfields and
greenbelt because greenbelt surrounds
our most popular towns to speculative
development
if you don't believe me or two of the
most experienced barristers in the
country believe other factual examples
in hatfield oxfordshire herefordshire
where greenbelt sites have been approved
for housing on appeal
with that and with regards specifically
to the greenbelt allocations that remain
in this plan in killer martian drumfield
as a point of principle i fully agree we
should never want to allocate sites on
the green belt i've spent a lot of time
talking to residents and members so i
know the strength of feeling in this
regard too
i share your frustration and upset at
where we're at but we have the evidence
base from the previous administration
strategy and the inspectors interim and
final judgment which supports the
release of these four remaining sites
and which would leave those four
remaining sites we're trying to protect
as well as other green belt sites
vulnerable even if we withdrew the plan
so it's in the context of these
competing issues to be frank what is a
rock and a hard place and the inability
to start completely from a clean slate
because of what's gone before but we all
have to make a choice and what we
individually think is the best for the
district today and as i hop both as a
whole and on an area by area basis
to then spend the final couple of
minutes with my local councillor
perspective as we all should too there
are sites in this plan i don't like and
certainly wouldn't have allocated from
speculative permissions which have been
granted to a couple of extras in
settlement gaps thanks to the previous
administration
as i've said throughout this speech we
can't rewind the clock and i really
regret that but we can stop the cycle of
speculative development eating up our
green fields in an unplanned and ad-hoc
manner
as a district and county councillor
living and representing sherland ward
and all the villages within it as well
as clay cross tucton and rasmall the key
discussion i've had with hundreds of my
neighbours and residents is the amount
of development we've faced and are
facing on green fields that we have not
been able to resist or plan for without
a plan in place
we know that the risk of continued
speculative development is real
there are applications right now in the
planning system that would likely be
ultimately approved if we don't have a
plan
the most imminent of those is the threat
of the 300 extra homes on coop lane
which i've been fighting against and
there will be many more that would
follow it
many more green fields where developers
have been refused in the past or are
waiting to put in applications if the
plan is not adopted in westington
sherland and the gaps between clay cross
tucton and winglet
please don't think our five-year housing
supply or the default of the tilted
balance and the mppf would protect us as
it wouldn't i don't even need to go out
of district to find examples of this as
dealings road william thought road never
more narrowly lane and coney green are
the devastating headline examples of
this
for the last decade it's been an awful
roulette where the odds have been
stacked against us and as one of the
local councillors for some of these
residents i've got a choice today and it
is a really imperfect choice but it's a
choice to end that i couldn't go back to
the communities i represent in the south
of the district voting against this plan
when i've worked so hard with them to
fight these speculative applications
so in summary there was no other there
was no alternative and it's a clear yes
or no choice today and that is a choice
please don't say this administration had
a choice to change other than to try
through the main modifications that was
an entirely viable option and the
examples of recent intervention
elsewhere in the country or the time
taken to start a game show the potential
consequences of withdrawing
i don't want to build on greenbelt as a
matter of principle and i respect those
who take that stance and i'll continue
to work with my conservative colleagues
to try and protect and mitigate those
sites whatever happens today
but on balance i personally have to be
swayed by what i believe will happen in
practice if the plan is not adopted and
so i move the recommendations i'm happy
to answer any questions share on a
factual basis as far as you can commit
during the debate or i'll try and sort
of round as many up in my closing
statement thank you thank you
comments all questions councillor barker
oh
corey
[Music]
thank you
thanks
for that
so we haven't got chance now after two
and a half years to to finally uh vote
on this local plan
uh in 2019
uh i think your group told the people in
northeast derbyshire
that you would pause the local plan
and allow it to be rewritten because of
your words or somebody's words it was
flawed he told them that the too many
houses were going to be built in the
wrong place
indeed as far as i understand you were
elected on a promise to remove the green
belt sites from this local plan before
going any further though i'd like to put
on record
uh put the record straight on some of
the misconceptions that they've been
banded about firstly i'd like to make it
crystal clear that the last
administration has always followed
government advice in drawing up this
local plan we followed the advice of our
excellent planning team
and even external consultants when we
put the plan together
i'll accept that the process did take a
long time but there were good valid
reasons for this
mostly around the extensive
consultations that had to be done and
the time period that that took up
the figure of thousand six hundred
hundred dollars has been used and it was
what it was arrived at for a valid
reason
members of the old group on the steering
group at the time voted to support that
figure
any number significantly less than that
had serious consequences for the
district but you forget to tell folks
that
secondly the decision to conduct to
review and building the green belt was
done for one reason and one reason only
it was the logical consequence of your
government's planning policies
that's a government government whose
mantra is build build build and which
wanted to change the law to make it
easier for developers to gain planning
permission we were told
very clearly and on several occasions
that the cross party local planned
steering group that submitting a local
plan without undertaking a green belt
review would not have been a realistic
option
and you've now come back to this council
with a plan endorsed by the planning
inspector that includes building those 6
600 properties and allows building on
the green boat
if anyone thinks that we started the
green belt review for some sort of
political kamikaze i thought i think
that asked you to think again
if we didn't voluntarily deal with that
many of you would have known or should
have known these fights from the outset
and you made promises and raised
expectations that you are
the cross party steering group has only
medical platons since the election
thus excluding others from that process
this leads me to the conclusion that
this plan is now very much your plan
to be honest i'm personally struggling
to support it even after reading the
legal advice
maybe if the steering group had met more
often
and some of the issues that we face
today have been could have been avoided
local plants split groups i'm sure
you're finding that out
some of us have seen the minute from
donfield town council and knows how
members of that council voted we also
know that your killer marsh members have
said and the promises they've made
so either some of the members are saying
different things at different meetings
or your group is split
on this issue
hardly surprising
since you're about to break the promises
you make of the people at drumfield and
killer marsh
you want with us to vote for this plan
and to be part of that deception so i in
good conscience can't do that
how do you use the steering group to
build a cross-party consensus things
could have been different
but you didn't
so i am minded to abstain on this one
thank you council market council
shipment
thank you chair um
i i agree with a lot of what um
councillor bach has just said i think
for our group
it's a matter of principle our group
stood at the 2019 election opposing the
local plan that was in existence then
the conservative group did you leaflet
said it your press release has said it
you oppose this local plan from the
start and you told residents that you
did not support it
two and a half years later you're now
trying to convince us to support it with
you like nigel says it's a trap it's it
you you're doing it because you've
misled residents and you have no other
choice now than to accept this bad local
plan because you've been messing around
for two and a half years that's how long
it's been it feels like yesterday but
you could go control two and a half
years ago
now in all of that time you could have
looked at amending the local plan
whether that's possible now is a
different story but you at the time two
and a half years ago council cupid's
just said to really write a full local
plan from scratch's four years well if
we've got two and a half years just to
make some amendments to the existing
local plan i think the planning team
here and the inspector could have
checked on it but changed that evidence
base that underpin the local plan what
you're doing now is misleading people
i've seen statements from councillor um
dale online where he's suggesting that
it's the inspector that changes the
local plan that is not true the council
submits a local plan the inspector
checks it based on the national planning
policy framework
to go around telling people that you're
being forced to have this local plan is
misleading everybody especially killer
martian drumful residents because that's
where the conservative group were most
vocal i will not be supporting this
local plan today and if any of the
conservative group do support this local
plan today you're seriously need to
consider your position because you have
lied to people you told people you
oppose this local plan and you cannot
honestly be now voting for it today
thank you chair
continue with comments all questions
count
right let me just
right now so council ac
right okay
this was a last minute thing for me to
present this
uh for a simple reason um
it was going to be a group
of residents asking questions and we're
told they couldn't because they needed
to give 12 days
notice now they couldn't give 12 days
notice for the simple reason the agenda
only come out a week before
so uh maybe we should change your policy
there okay
this is this all refers to site kl-1
and training some flooding
apart from the main route of sheffield
road kilomoles has two access routes
that are prone to flooding this is
stinky hill road and green lane
i've sent all councillors a couple of
photographs of a couple of occasions
where this happened
uh
there's a culvert
for the rainwater to park brook via some
detention ponds on the site
the site this site has a 43 meter drop
from north east to southwest
causes flooding to the site
in periods of sustained rain
which now occur more regularly it's now
no longer now a hundred year event
and uh
the removal of most of the wildflowers
in the meadow
will deny the current grasslands ability
to absorb excess water
and i don't believe
climbable materials will be used on the
development
to remove most of the wildflower meadows
will deny the current grout grasslands
the ability to absorb excess water and
this will lead
later soil instability
due to removal of the complex structure
the wildflowers which provide current
stability
i believe these ish issues contravene
sdc 11 paragraphs 1c and 2d
that the site should be removed from the
plan
that is it
thank you council cornwell
over the last couple years oh i'm the
district councillor
over the last few years in homewood
we've seen five developments
totaling 1100 properties
mostly in the last two and a half years
our population has gone from 3900
and has almost doubled to 6 000 people
now i've been telling people in homewood
that we are unlikely to manage to stop
any of these developments even if we
didn't do manage to get to appeal and we
did manage to get to appeal for several
of them
the reason we can't stop them is because
we've got no local plan and the officers
have absolutely no grounds to stop it
so
i'm absolutely dismayed that this local
plan has been sat with you guys for two
and a half years
and what seems to be very little changes
possibly to protect areas where my
conservative colleagues are represent
so
heath and homewood have have received
the brunt of the lack of a local plan
we're no longer homewood but we're
practically connected to clay cross
north wingfield and temple normanton and
we could be actually renamed as clay
northwoodton
because there has been no local plan so
i have absolutely no choice but to vote
for this because i have i have to give
every little bit of hope that way we can
save whatever land is left in homewood
and give our officers the chance to stop
any new developments i don't necessarily
want to vote for it i have no choice to
protect homewood
thank you counselor and chaos are off
thank you chair
it is my intent to support the local
plan before us today
this plan is long overdue on that i'm
sure we can all agree
and although not perfect and it never
could be with such a diverse district
with differing needs from hamlets to
villages towns this plan is the only one
before us today
we are all aware of the challenges that
face the district to meet its housing
provision and today north east can
demonstrate that not only have we met
the number but we have in fact exceeded
it
unfortunately it has to be said it is
the southern part of the district that
has formed the brunt
of the major developments
when the worth alone having over 1600
new homes not including infill sites
by not backing the local plan before us
today
we could potentially open the floodgates
to get more speculative development
across the whole district
and this would include all green belt
sites
i would urge particularly all southern
murderers to support this plan
and i do take exception to be called a
liar
i have never had in my risks given to my
residents the fact that i would
not protect them from development
this is one of the things i stood
originally as a counsellor
and i do take exception to that
with this in mind i shall be seconding
this recommendation thank you chair
thank you council ruff
council cloth
thank you chair
my comments today
relate to policies ss1 and assist two
now that two and our sides to eking to
coal aston and drug field have been
quite rightly removed from the
allocations kill marsh is left with the
largest delegation of dwellings amongst
all those towns in tier one and two
in the north of the district killer most
allocation of of a total of 560
dwellings should be compared with the
total allocations of dronfield and
eckington combined which is 516.
kilomarch has about 11 000 residents
whereas dronfield eckington between them
have about 35 000 residents
additionally killer marsh has the
smallest amount of green belts the least
amount of grease green space per head of
population
and the poorest infrastructure
according to figures within the plan
how is this fair reasonable and
proportionate to reflect killer marsh's
position in the settlement hierarchy and
accord with policies ss1 and ss2
i don't believe this plan delivers for
killer marsh or the district as a whole
and therefore i will be voting against
can i ask that my brother is is is love
that is registered please
thank you can you just remind some
counselors still have microphones on
because it creates two of my voice and
you don't want that
thank you any other comments council
pots
and then council hancock
[Music]
thank you chair for having the
opportunity to speak
residents in killer marsh as well as
being concerned about adding to an
already congested village road system
about an inadequate infrastructure about
worsening an existing flooding issue and
about a lack of public transport are
also concerned about the environmental
effects of opening up development on our
green belt as proposed in this plan
before us today
the environmental and ecological impact
resulting from the development of the
west thought kl1 site in the plan would
be significantly damaging
this would include habitat loss
pollution from dust spoils and runoff
fragmentation or isolation of habitats
and disturbance injury and possible
destruction of fauna
of the 14 hedgerows on the site five are
judged to be ecologically important
under the 1997 hedgerows regulations
development of this site will require
the removal whole or in part of
virtually all 14 hedgerows and 8 mature
trees will also be felt
there have been 66 species of bird
recorded as using the site 15 of which
are on the rspb red list five species of
fat user sites and great crested mutes
are also believed to be on the site
it is appreciated that while some of the
damage could be ameliorated the overall
impact would be ecologically destructive
and would fall short of this council's
own policies
namely policy sdc2 trees woodland and
hedgerows
and policy sdc4 for the biodiversity and
geodetic diversity policy
there is a strong public opinion in
killer marsh that the environmental and
ecological well-being of killer marsh's
green belt
kl1 site should not be sacrificed as
proposed in this plan
i was elected to fight development on
this on the site
and i will vote accordingly today thank
you
thank you council hancock
thank you chair um
i've spent two terms now arguing that
the local plan that we've had before as
is not appropriate for northeast
derbyshire my opinion hasn't altered i
am going to actually correct a few
issues here and i would thank councillor
cuba for her very freudian slip earlier
when she was speaking and she mentioned
nevermore road nether more road is the
perfect example of speculative
development that was kicked out and was
upheld at appeal because it simply
wasn't there so to use the threat of
speculative development is misleading
the public and everyone in this room
we can oppose where we have strong
rights to do so and this council has had
almost three years to have set the ball
rolling on an alternative local plant we
didn't have to go with main
modifications we could have restarted
the clock we could have gone we could
have been a hell of a long way down that
road right now and fighting for actually
to protect the um
the environment that we have
i can't support it um i mean even the
barristers report which has been used i
presume as an attempt to convince people
actually says that our existing local
plan does still carry weight
it may be an old policy it may have
reduced weight but it does still carry
weight
and i think um that the most appropriate
thing is and and yes we have gone two
and a half years down the line
it is still to reject this local plan
and look at an alternative and i would
ask all members to consider that because
this is not in the district's best
interest thank you chair
thank you just let you know where i move
the list i've got council cooper next
now i'm going to council tate and
angelique foster and then council
dramaal then council platz so council
cooper thank you chair
uh as a as a planning member on this uh
council i find it increasingly difficult
and with no up-to-date local plan
indeed i find that i find it very
difficult in fact some days i find it
like a joiner going out to work with no
tools
only to look up to find the developers
have stolen them all
i will be supporting this today
not because i think it's exactly the
right thing but i think
because of what's gone before and the
history i think it's the only thing that
we can do consciously today to make to
try and make things somewhere near right
i represent pilsley morton and stretton
and pilsley and morton in particular
have had
a lot of development over the last few
years
and i'm just very concerned that if we
don't accept this today
that's just going to continue and
continue and it's going to be once again
the south of the district that's going
to suffer the most thank you chair
thank you council cooper council tate
thank you chair and thank you for the
opportunity to speak on the local plan i
stand here today as a parent resident
town and district councillor for this
local ban great effects
since the plan emerged i've been
fighting against it with some and all
councils here in this room today
as a i stood beside these councils and
promised to fight a local plan which
include included building on greenbelt
my position on the local plan has not
changed
you'll hear other councils here today
speaking against and for the slovaklan
and they themselves are between a rock
and a hard place as i'm sure you will
hear
some might say there are risks of
starting again
but one thing i do know is that green
belt protects itself from being
developed and by approving this local
plan and the removal of land from
greenbelt that protection is lost
forever
let's not forget the 4 000 signatures
submitted to this very council to save
the green belt that is four thousand
drumfield residents
who felt so strongly about losing the
green belt they started a petition
i'd also like to take this opportunity
to go to council from across the room
and share their concerns when speaking
about upon application which sought to
build on greenbelt on the 9th of
february this year
and i quote councillor reader
a real concern about what is happening
in greenville
we want to protect the green belt to
stop things from sprawling out
i hope the council reader stands by her
words in that planning meeting here
today as voting against this local plan
would also protect the green belt and
stop things from falling out
i would also like to take this
opportunity to ask for my vote to be
recorded
i believe this local plan does not
benefit the residents in my ward which
i'm here representing today thank you
thank you council angelique foster
thank you
before i start just to clarify something
i've been a counselor
for north east davisha district since
2011
and at the time it was in the labor we
didn't have a local plan then and it had
been in the
hands of labor for many many years and
they failed to bring us a proper local
plan we've had only two and a half years
to work on this plan i'm here today
speaking on behalf of john phil south
presidents i've been their counsellor
for 11 years but also for all other drum
fair residents as john furrier town
council leader which have been for the
last six years
as such i've played many times that i
would fight to protect our green belt i
promised i would fight this local plan
until all our green belt sites were
removed from the plan
i was at the forefront of the campaign
against the local plan when it was first
presented in fact even before that i had
made my views very clear on behalf of
residents
and i'd like to clarify as well that
nowhere at no time in drone field have i
ever seen any lib dem counselors or
members of the parties joining us in
that fight ever
none of them so it's very good to be
standing stood here and trying to speak
against it and making political points
we never i had any help whatsoever from
the lib dems in drumfield i'd like that
minute please
i've worked closely for many years with
residents community groups and my fellow
counselors to object to this plan while
it was under labour
and since then i participated in the
public inquiry meetings and helped
coordinate responses
and i carried on in some way during the
last consultations back in 2020
i don't think anybody can be in any
doubt about my position today
i don't expect that anything i say today
will change your mind
every counselor here will have come
today knowing full well which way they
will vote
because all the information on this plan
has been available to all of us for many
many months
so i will not go into the details of why
i will vote against this plan because
these have been put forward many times
over
over the many times over by our various
forums
just a couple of points the voice of
john phil residents has been loud and
clear they trust us that we will protect
our green belt at all cost in 2019 john
14 council presented its neighborhood
plan voted through by referendum and
recognized and made
by this very council
in it residents made it very clear that
they wanted the local green belt
preserved and protected and they put
forward evidence
for the reason for the reasons why
two significant greenbelt sites remain
in the plan the green belt side dr-1 and
dr dr3 which are key green belt sites
that still fulfill
all green belt criteria
and it has been suggested earlier
actually that those fields that fields
elsewhere in the district
that do not currently have green belt
protection
are at risk if we don't give up those
green belts sites it does not make sense
to me
dr1 has even further been assessed for
flood risk most recently following the
issues faced by unstoned properties a
couple of years ago this assessment
shows that any development on that land
will cause significant further flooding
risk to those same unstoned properties
junkful town council has provided a
number of alternative sites which again
were supported by residents still
greenbelt sites are being prioritized
and we all know that because in most
part they are easier to develop
for developers
we've also been told that rejecting the
plan today present a number of risks are
referred to the barristers report
received
but let's take example of amber valley
borough council for example where amber
valley councillors made the very
decision to scrap their local plan a
couple of years ago because in their
view it put too much green belts up for
development
now their new plan contains much less
green belt sites than originally
the inspector has been provided with
ample evidence half a minute left to
show that our green bar sites should
remain protected
but neither the inspector nor the
barrister are making the decision today
every single councillor here are making
the decision
and they should vote to protect our
green belt at all costs
i will vote against the plan today
and it is because it is a matter of
conscience that i want the public to
know that
i would like my personal vote to be
limited and i believe there are rules
the rules are in the constitution that
allow for that so i'd like my vote to be
recorded
thank you council foster council drabble
thank you jeff
um killer marsh what other areas in the
northeast davis district has poor air
quality mostly caused by the proximity
of the eight lanes of m1 mode while
you're showing in the map on page 24 of
the scoping report for the
sustainability appraisal of the north
east armstrong
core strategy published in february
2012.
this will have worsened since this due
to the eight lanes of smart motorway
that are now fully operational have been
since april 2016.
the report was in 2012.
site kl1 is less than a mile away from
near one and kl2 is even closer with kl1
being more than two kilometers from the
facilities of killer marsh
and site kl tourist repairs at the
furthest northern point of kilomarch
the sustainability appraisal of the plan
states that site kl1 will engender a
significant increase in greenhouse gas
emissions
additionally a kl1 site contains
contaminated soil much of which will
have to be taken away by lorries or
extracted and used as the bay is for the
roadways
this will inevitably cause dust to fall
on the houses driveways and roads
surrounding the site with some of the
contamination
including polycyclic aromatic
hydrocarbons potentially cancer causing
there has not been an air quality
assessment on this site and in my view
that should have been i believe that the
development of this site will be both
dangerous to kill a mass residents not
just at a local site level
and contrary to policy stc 13 paragraphs
1 2 and paragraph 4 in respect of the
lack of a full air quality assessment
why has this unsuitable site been
included in the allocations and can i
also request for my votes to be known to
check thank you thank you council platz
this is my feedback relates
sustainability um around the local plan
in particular marsh the two sites
proposed for removal from the green belt
in kilomarch do not meet any of the
three requirements under paragraph 79 of
the 2012 national planning policy
framework
in terms of economic value there are two
protected employment sites available in
kilomarsh both of which are unattractive
to developers
both have been protected sites since the
last local plan and the aspirin alberti
employment sites review 2017 which
placed both sites in the red category
stating that they would not be available
for 10 years
and would need significant investments
become viable the sites are located far
away from the town centre and would need
travel by car to access services
contrary to policy ss1 ie where services
and facilities are accessible by foot
cycle or public transport with reduced
reliance on the private car
the social element of sustainability
requires a sufficient number and range
of homes we provided including
affordable homes the viability issues in
respective site kl1 is highly unlikely
to reach 20 perhaps even any affordable
home provision due to massive
remediation costs required by the site's
former mining legacy
the environment and ecology of the site
will be damaged irreparably by this
development as evidenced by a report
from access psychology stating that
there will be significant damage caused
to ecology and sitelocation
this will include habitat loss
disturbance and damage to habitats
pollution from dust spoiling runoffs
fragmentation and isolation of habitats
and disturbance and injury or death to
fauna
some of the effects can be ameliorated
but by no means all the damage will be
permanent and surely contravenes the
2012
national
planning policy framework and policy sd4
which requires the enhancement of all
sites of biogeo diversity
site ko2 also has very similar issues to
site ko1
you know
the question it begs the question why
these sites particularly kl once
still left in the local plan
um
overall
i can't in good conscience
support the play
um
our constituents in in our area have
pressed against this for many years now
many many years um and as such i weren't
voting for the plan
and again i would like that logging also
in the minutes
thank you council lewis
uh thank you uh chairman um
i thank you for this opportunity to
speak on this one i wasn't going to but
um having heard some of the discussions
i thought that um i better put my uh
topham's worth in
um the local plan has always caused me
or the lack of a local plan especially
has always caused me some uh discomfort
um locally for a number of reasons the
issue for me isn't the local plan per se
but i do accept that there are arguments
around the green belt but
some parts of our community in the
northeast derbyshire have
the issue for me is that not having a
local plan leaves the door open to
speculative development and we have seen
a considerable amount of that in
our communities
most especially
um in around my own uh village
of westington but also in places like
sherland and the impacts in winger with
in particular in my ward have been
very uh very significant so right across
my division as a county councillor and
those uh those those issues of wrong are
really loud and hard for us
um
so
the speculative uh building over the
last 10 years has done more damage to
our towns and villages i think in
certainly my parts and no doubt in other
um um elected members parts of the uh of
north east derbyshire and perhaps um
have not been doing the local plan
itself a local plan means there will be
rocks and hard places as it's been
described for all of us
but no local plan means greater impacts
and more
more losers than winners i think um
across our communities i'll be
supporting it albeit reluctantly i'm
afraid thank you
council dale
thank you uh chet
i just want to start by
addressing some of the points made by
councillor barker and
the the lib dems
i think that labour's position if if
labour are abstaining
is a complete abdication of
responsibility
residents won't forget that you may say
that about what the conservatives are
doing today but residents won't forget
your involvement in this plan
it's been it's been you had the last the
last plan was adopted in 2005.
you had 14 years
you had 14 years
to adopt a local plan
and you failed at every hurdle and the
speculative development that we've heard
about is a direct result of not having a
local plan in place
we've had thousands of homes approved in
the south in particular
as a result of not having that plan in
place and it's no use claiming it on
government con government guidelines or
extensive consultations you had 14 years
you had the ability to set out a better
plan from the outset and my biggest
single regret is that the elections
didn't happen in 2018 and we could have
we could have taken control and we could
have more easily started the pun again
having not had the the examination uh to
happen in the meantime uh in terms of
the dems i mean this is just classic
political bandwagon jumping i have to
ask myself where were you during all the
consultations in drumfield did you even
submit a response to the latest
consultation point to point of view
because council fosters said this early
and i would like to correct both of them
we were heavily involved in fact i
wasn't even elected then councillor
hancock was actually absolutely what
point of order are you actually
referring to i think i think both need
to correct the statements because
they're misleading future
there's no point of order raised there
can we prep
i think it's absolutely fitting that the
libdems think there's an extremely
simple solution to all of this and
actually it shows how little they
understand the planning process
and their only alternative was a huge
new development in the green belt to the
rural west of the district how on earth
would that help to protect the green
belt how on earth would that be
sustainable it's just absolutely
ridiculous that they can even suggest
that their alternative was better
i think from my perspective and for me
this is one of the hardest decisions
i've ever had to make as a counselor
but it's ultimately what we're elected
to do and in saying that i'd start by
saying that i fully respect the decision
of all colleagues
to arrive at different conclusions on
this and that's why i think it's
important that the conservative group is
having a free vote we all have to be
guided by our own views and
the interpretation of the facts before
us so i can only speak uh to the
situation as i see it
alongside local residents and community
groups and fellow councillors i've
played an important role in the in the
campaign to protect the green belt over
the past four years since the first
draft was with football in 2017
you know some of the some of the actions
fellow colleagues have already outlined
organizing public meetings delivering
leaflets collecting petition signatures
holding advice surgeries supporting
residents in what say in their own
consultation responses attending the
examination sessions and as
an administration since 2019 no stone
has been unturned in trying to find a
way forward to remove the remaining
green belt sites without putting the
rest of the green belt and particularly
those sites already removed from the
plan back at risk
the simple fact for me is that the plan
is at too late of a stage in a heavily
legal legally regulated process where
changes cannot be achieved without
risking what the barrister highlights in
the appendix
it's a deep matter it's a matter of deep
regrets that we haven't been able to
find a way of successfully and safely
removing the green belt allocations but
i know that we've done everything within
our power to try
ultimately it's down to all members to
come down on a risk-based judgment from
my perspective clearly there are risks
in voting for the plan at not least that
those sites allocated are then highly
likely to face development
but for me the risks of not adopting a
plan are too significant to ignore the
point that counselor cupid has already
made around the 2000 additional houses
by resetting the plot we'd have to find
i i failed to see how he would do that
without further encroachment on the
green belt there would also be the issue
of the duty to cooperate
we would have to factor in with
sheffield still formulating its local
plan
we'd face an increased risk of
speculative development across the
district and from from what i read of
the the barrister's appendix the green
belt itself would not necessarily be
safe
in fact my own view is that the site's
currently allocated as sad as i am to
say it
i you know this the inspector has found
that the exceptional circumstances uh
have been met in those cases and i think
that they would be extremely difficult
to defend it appeal but i'm also
concerned that we'll face more
applications on the green belt due to
how to date the plan would become
and while clearly we would do everything
as a council we could to stop them i
can't we i couldn't guarantee to
residents that would be successful and i
think that prospect of going backwards
in terms of what we've achieved on the
green belt is my biggest fear other
councillors clearly will have a
different interpretation of those risks
and that is completely
for them to them to come to
but but it's fundamentally a decision
around those risks and while it pains me
to vote for a plan which contains sites
that i've had so much effort in trying
to fight i cannot ignore what icefield
are the very significant risks we face
and for that reason i'll be voting for
the recommendation it's not a decision i
take lightly and i've very carefully
considered all of the issues thank you
councillor dale thank you chair council
reader
thank you victor
i wasn't also going to speak today but i
think council takes put me in the
position where i have to
i absolutely stand by those comments and
i think
you need to understand that everybody on
this side of the chamber
it's been sort of led to the this belief
that labour wants to build in greenbelt
and we absolutely don't want to build in
greenbelt
we were faced with a decision
of making a plan we did that
hand on heart i believe
with the
guidance that was put forward for us
which is government guidance i don't
know what guidance you would be using
but we use the guidance that's presented
to us on this side of the chamber
and that is what we truly did and also
the respect for the officers who put the
time and the hours in to advise us
on the best course of action and they
advised us on what we had to do
so absolutely everybody on this side of
the chamber followed the guidance that
we were given
so yes it is a difficult decision
so on this side of the chamber we've
also taken a free vote because we
understand
that there are going to be communities
upset by this plan
there are going to be councillors like
in my ward in the south that have been
absolutely decimated with building
clay lane coupling it's absolutely
atrocious what's happening with those
sites and i've been there fighting for
those sites to be saved
i have i've spoken on the clay lane site
i've been up and down coop lane with
councillor ralph
spent a full day down there talking to
residents down there
we don't want building down there and
we'll continue to fight like that for
those residents there
so with this side of the chamber we'll
absolutely be taking a free vote in what
they truly believe is the best vote for
their community
thank you council reader counterinik
yes thank you chair i'm also finding
this very difficult vote i represent
atkinson killer marsh and colason
i was hugely delighted that after all
the works particularly with councillor
kenyon attending
the committee at the time uh we removed
kolasinackington but now i'm finding
myself as a
killer martial county councillor not
quite successful which is hugely
disappointing
um the heavy heart i will be voting for
this but um just wanted to point out
that
the local plan is not the same as
planning permission being granted and i
hope through the planning process and
the planning committee that's anything
that's from the killer marsh end is
scrutinized and makes sure that we um
for all the reasons people have raised
i'm surprised it's still in there and we
need to redouble our efforts depending
on the outcome of this vote today to
make sure that sites we're not happy
with we fight all those sites tooth and
nail thank you council hall
thank you good afternoon chair i'd just
like to pick up on well page 35 appendix
number one with any regis residents read
it reading this could be concerned with
the independent legal advice on the
risks of not adopting the local plan
from cornerstone barristers now anyone
reading it may argue that uh what are
the risks of adopting a local plan and
why is there just been uh well they
could see it as a bit of a one-sided
view in a way
should we not have a
another barrister's report saying what
are the risks of
are we adopting the local plan we've
heard that with a local plan
um it may minimize appeals but even
we're
reminded to vote for this
there's nothing to stop any appeals
coming forward including on the site two
sites that have always already been uh
withdrawn from from the
plan thank you
thank you council hall i'm sure council
cupid will respond to that question
in a summing up
council mark foster
thank you chair uh first of all i want
to make two things very clear before i
start first one is i'm not questioning
anyone else's integrity here so i'll let
that sink in
second one is i want that uh to ask that
my own vote be recorded under rule 14.5
as others have said of the constitution
and that is certainly not a request for
a full recorded vote it's a request for
my book to be recorded for the record
uh most people have already heard me
speak on the local plan before so none
of this will be a surprise
i'm sure you've heard all of this before
my views remain the same i was against
this plan in opposition
during the last election when we took
control of the council and right up to
this final point
at every turn and every opportunity i've
advocated scrapping the plan
every time without a fail and you've all
let me say
over the years i've spoken to many
residents on the door in village halls
at greenbelt residence meetings in the
street collecting signatures for the
petition with all the four and a half
thousand signatures
their voice of all the all these people
it was overwhelming overwhelmingly
against building on the green belt and
against this local plan
and let's not get this mixed up here
these are the same thing the plan takes
land out of the green belt so you can
build on it we understand that i know
that
residents know that and certainly
developers know about that
so if you look at the website and this
is a pertaining to killer marsh of urban
town planning they've already requested
through the local plan that land at west
west thorpe killer marsh be removed from
the green belt so that uh our estates
can build 400 houses on it it's an oven
ready plan for killer marge and it's
exactly the same for drumfield it's
exactly the same
um
so this is not a done deal
today is our final vote this is it today
yeah
it is however a done deal after today if
this plan goes through
now i'm on the planning committee and we
all know when these planning
applications come in it will sell the
application that the council already
have effectively given approval based on
the local plan that's what it will say
so residents will come and talk about
doctor's appointments and school places
like they usually do and we listen to
them but these aren't taken into account
a local counsellor might do a survey and
say i'm against this and we'll fight
this particular one and i know sorry
council i think you mentioned this
earlier so my apologies it's opposite to
what you've said uh but they'll come and
talk about increased traffic and can we
have some 106 money but none of this
will matter because our planning
department will be recommending approval
based on this local plan that's what it
will come through us it will be based on
this local plan that we're voting on
today so fighting the net planning
committee is not going to happen
i'll try but that's a constant on the
planning committee
that's why i will not vote for the local
plan and it is not supported as it's not
supported by residents i do not support
building on greenbelt land never have
done and never will i don't mind the
accusations from the lib dems i don't
mind them one bit because they're not
true
they're not so i don't mind hearing them
at all
and lastly i've asked that my own
individual vote be minuted so that
residents know that i've listened to
them this listening council business i'm
a listening counselor and they've heard
and have i've heard them i want them in
that camera to know that i've heard them
and i'm voting this way because of that
uh the last thing i'd say and i'd add to
this uh because this is rewritten and
normally do speak off the call but i've
written this before
what i would say is this when we look at
people look at this from the outside
they'll see that our party's split we've
got a free vote we've heard the free
vote from the labour side and i've heard
the commitments from the lib dems what i
can't get is anybody not voting near me
on it
yeah they will see that the balance of
the power lies on the labor side they
will see that out there so let's hear
somebody standing up you up for it or
you bought against it let's stand up and
stand fast
thank you chair
thank you council foster council kenyan
and just so people know where they are
i've got council windley next council
welton and councillor wright
thank you chair
local plans are to ensure that every
part of the country plays its fair role
providing housing for a rapidly rising
population and in spite of the current
temporary blip that rise will continue
and it has its roots in not in planning
policy recent planning policy but in
political decisions taken decades ago
and sadly now we reap the problems of
those decisions and difficult choices
have to be made so that housing does not
become even more unaffordable pricing
young and old out of the market
i would also just uh on the recent
comments say the local plan is
permission to apply for planning it is
absolutely not a free pass and there are
extensive requirements on any planning
application and even stricter ones on
the ones in the greenbelt and that is
covered in the local plan itself
i'd like to say a bit about the
examination process as it was so key to
improve improving the plan of the
previous administration
that process which is an independent one
started in 2018 but it only ended
earlier this year following consultation
on modifications
i was there for almost every minute of
the weeks of hearings of that final
examination not as a spectator but as an
active participant working to get that
plan modified and protect our greenbelt
from unnecessary development spending
weeks pouring over the evidence
questioning its conclusions and showing
its weaknesses to the independent
inspector
and as some in our audience and the
public will know as they were also there
there were many people doing the same
members of rage in killer marsh members
of dromfield civic society members of
trumpfield town council our conservative
mp
and conservative councillors from across
the district and we had very significant
success
our collective efforts reduced the belt
housing from 1275 houses just just 600
saving over half the green belt that the
previous administration had included in
their plan
so
the examination was the last time to
amend that plan not the local planned
working group that was referred to
and not the council it was beyond their
remit at that point
and any counsellor could have put along
to that examination
including uh council shipment and
council of barker
but
the examination was open to anybody
absolutely
but what i don't remember is a string of
councillors from other parties coming
along sat around that table day after
day
it's not rubbish it's uh
counselor kenyan i was there most days
day after day
thank you can we just uh i think we'll
accept you were there and then let's
press on with you i accept counselor
alexa you were there and let's hash on
with us came along yes
i i concur on council hancock council
right you mind
i've also been astonished even more by
the rewriting of history that some are
attempting via facebook it's public
record who submitted motions opposing
this plan who submitted objections
written objections to the inspector and
residents know who for years was working
to campaign against that local plan
but the real work of politics is huge
amounts of time spent researching
thinking discussing
understanding and making a real and
considered case for change and that is
what this conservative administration
focused on throughout the last three
years
but ultimately we are where we are the
plan for us is both about allowing
development in some limited locations in
greenbelt and about protecting
everywhere else against speculative
development
and i also believe that our incredibly
robust challenge to the local plan left
no stone unturned including many of the
ones mentioned today
i recognize we are all in a difficult
position and i fully appreciate why some
councillors may vote against
but because of the need to protect all
our other greenbelt from speculative
development and our other green spaces
and greenfields and all those bits of
infill
um
and the need to provide such housing i
will reluctantly be supporting this plan
thank you chad
thank you councilwoman
in response to councillor foster's
comments councillors hancock and shipman
met with dr goodison
and the save the drumfield greenbelt
team on many occasions
we have actively worked with both the
north and the south of the district to
try and resolve this situation
without playing the two halves of the
district against each other
this local plan fails to meet the needs
of the district and i'll be voting
against it
[Music]
i'm speaking against the adoption of the
local plan and will be voting against
i've been completely consistent from
2015 2019 every single occasion i've
been completely consistent about voting
against this local plan
normally at the end but this is
important to me and the rule 14.5
that my personal vote is recorded into
the minutes the reason is
people in my ward and in wrongfield need
to know where i stand like others here
i've also attended i attended i've been
on the streets i've done public
consultations
i've been to the inspectors
and i think i've been very consistent to
this
if i'm saying what's different about
sheffield and derbyshire to people you
know elsewhere in the country or
overseas one of the things i say we're
unique in that we're surrounded by
countryside i lived in birmingham for
seven eight years and you can go from
solid hall to dudley and see nothing but
industrial estates and roads and
concrete and houses
that is not the same
here and one of the reasons is our green
belt is very old 1938 second oldest in
the country 240 000 hectares it goes
before that sheffield society protection
of local scenery to 1924 the sheffield
city council started buying up land
and the reason why this is important and
one thing said that the exhibit the
existing local plan i said the previous
local plan to provide some level of
weight which is correct
is that because it's very old it
bestows a very high level of protection
not a hundred percent because everything
derived from planning
but a very high level of protection
and in this i've done other people i've
spoke with university departments i've
spoken to lawyers i've spoken developers
i've spoken to plc's
so that isn't just something i've come
up with myself
so i believe that the local plan will
actually remove grain belt it doesn't
protect green belt first of all because
the existing green belt sites will be
built on because the presumption then
will be you build on them
so it doesn't protect green belt
the second reason is that the local plan
is a mechanism an effective mechanism
for taking greenbelt out
and giving it to developers or
speculators for a profit
that's what it does because otherwise
it'll be very difficult
if you allow these green belt incursions
to go it will encourage more developers
these are bridgeheads
whatever comes next is a white paper on
planet whatever it's going to be whether
it's a traffic light system whatever
it's going to be
this will encourage further encroachment
it will reduce the protection
the actual existing lp is on stale
it's on 2011 census and out-of-date
settlement hierarchy review which was
flawed
we've got plenty of brownfield sites
but the world has changed it's changed
with covert it's changed with technology
we've seen the retail sector completely
change there are enough sites
so i think lp will need to increase
developer pressure
here and elsewhere in the district
i want to touch briefly on the
neighbourhood plan i spent three years
with a number of drone field councillors
three years on that
it was a lot of time and that went to a
referendum that was approved by
trumpfieltain council it was approved by
the district
and it went for comp public consultation
and it was approved in the referendum
and part of that is the adoption emv1
policy
that there is a strong presumption
against development on greenbelt and
that's been adopted by
all
there is very little
not 100 but there's very little public
support to building on greenbelt
in strongfield
i also want to draw your attention to
the capr the uh council
center for economic and
uh business uh research we're on the top
of the top 10
areas to live in the country and one of
them is the access to green spaces and
the end of settlement limits which one
of the sites my own dr3
will do
so i have not changed my opinion you've
got half a minute left okay so in my
opinion the lp framework is not in the
best interests of dronfield residents
bronfield woodhouse and gospels valley
which is my award and i will be opposing
it thank you
chair to welton check can i call a
recorded vote second goodbye can we just
finish the i'll come back to that so we
don't skip it and you tell me we can't
do it because we've gone past that would
i
brian right
thank you
not a lot just to
endorse the fact that i am i am always
i've been and always will be against
building and development in the green
belt
and just the other thing is that i would
like to
have my vote recorded personally on the
rule 14
thank you
thank you any other comments or
questions
you've spoken counselor lazy now
so we've got to request recorded though
is that supported by council hancock
need a third one council winley so
that's it we have a recorded vote i'm
going to turn now to council cupid to
reply
thank you jeff sorry i can get my muscle
um
thank you for i think what has been
quite an interesting debate and i
appreciate it so it's a passionate
debate and i welcome the fact that we
have all set out our views um to try and
cover as many of the queries as that as
i can um before my pen ran out um
the local plan uh steering group
wouldn't have changed things councillor
barca because there was nothing left to
steer and i do because we were in the
legal process and i do contest
uh the point that several labour
colleagues have made that
you didn't set the strategy because you
did although i do fully appreciate the
work officers have done back then and
now and throughout this process and i
sort of acknowledge that and thank them
for that
we didn't start this process if we had i
genuinely believed we would be in a
different place
politics and planning as i said at the
start does require hard decisions and i
think that's what we've seen from
today's debate and that's what residents
have to trust us to do we can't shy away
from that difficult decision but i would
like to reiterate in contrast to what
some members have said about the
opportunity to amend that that was not
an option we've done a lot of work on
this over the last two years and because
we'd received the inspector's report to
try and make changes we'd have had to
declare and prove the set plan and sound
which by itself would draws you from the
examination and then we'd have had to
meet the stages or principles and
modifications not to take too long and
not and for them to be a modification
which again because of the evidence base
we couldn't have done so adopt an
amendment was not an option it was a
forum against and it is a forum against
today
as i've said for members in drumfield
and killermarsh i recognise the points
that have been made and the different
stances that may be taken but for
members representing wards in the south
or the west i want to just reiterate
what happens without an adopted plan
counselor shipment and council of
hancock have said that you know you
could sub out sites but that shows a
fundamental misunderstanding and it is
also misleading residents as your own
favorite phrase and trying to political
point score on an issue
i appreciate you nobody can answer me
now but given intended the intended
stance particularly of the lib dem group
i'd like you to think how you're going
to explain to residents in the south
that you signed up for there to be no
settlement development limits separating
wingworth tucked and grassmore or play
cross especially when you've used that
in your own objections on nethermore
road and the same goes for councillor
hancock that that same objection of
settlement development limits was used
in the nethermore road appeal which
again really pleased that we won but
that was also because we had a local
plan
and just to quote just to quote that as
if that doesn't if you're saying that
you don't think that that was important
to nevermore road just to quote from the
deal and road in appeal inspector
settlement development limits are
meaningless if there are no state
policies to support them so it shows
that it can go both ways
and as a final point i just want to come
back to some of the queries on killer
marsh that have been raised specifically
i understand the questions and concerns
and a lot of the the issues that have
been raised will be considered as part
of the planning process which will
happen regardless of what happens with
today's vote as there's a live
application on that site particularly on
kl1
i appreciate the challenges that members
have raised in killer marsh which we've
also raised with the inspector but the
answer is again that we've been locked
into a legal process
regarding the question about spatial
strategy i fully understand the concerns
of local residents members that this is
unfair but the problem we have is what i
outlined in my opening speech and what
i'll close with is that we don't have a
clean slate to start from as we've
always been in a legal process and have
received the inspectors interim findings
which declared that site and the green
belt site sound
now it's a judgment for us all to make
for or against but we have to
balance that with the risk of more
speculative or disproportionate
growth yeah so thank you chair happy to
move to the vote
thank you it's been proposed by council
cupid seconded by council ruff
and so we are now going to move to
recorded vote so i'm going to hand over
to the monitoring officer for the roll
call please
thank you chairman i'm going to read
your names in reverse order
and could you please tell me if you're
voting for against or abstaining
counselor p right
[Music]
councillor welton against council the
council rouse abstain
councillor
council renwick
council reader
against
council powell
liggett
for
councillor lewis
council lacey
councillor kerry
councillor kenyon
poor
councillor hutchinson
councillor hartshorn
abstain
cancer hancock
against council hall
against councillor gomez gomezrini
for
council finale
councillor m foster
against councillor a foster against
councillors
or council cornwall for
councillor cooper
council club
against council birkin
abstain
answer barry
i'll say
councillor barker out today
cancer armitage
for
and councillor and cliff
so the results are as follows 22 votes
for
16 against
seven abstentions
so
the plan is carried
item 10
to answer any questions from members
asked under procedure rule 9.2 no
questions have been submitted so move to
item 11 to consider motions from members
under procedure rule number 10 and we've
had one
can we
so
apologies so we have one motion proposed
by council shipman over to you please
counter shipment thank you chair um
this was off the back of the headline
where where the council has lost out on
almost 200 000 section 106 money
following
i believe two companies going bust
subsequently into them actually doing
the development that we've approved
based on them providing that section 106
agreement and i thought it'd be it was
it's been wise for us to actually have
this debate
because it's one of those things that
yes it's a technical issue
but this is two hundred thousand pounds
that northeastern residents are losing
whether it's residents in ridgeway or
residents in moreton in this case that
are losing out on that affordable
housing contribution or local recreation
facilities and i think that the council
should take steps to try and avoid this
happening in future whether that's to
lobby the government to bring in
legislation to actually do something
about it whether it's council policy we
can change perhaps that's something that
the leader and the deputy leader could
go ahead and
make changes internally but i do believe
that we need to address this because
this is not just pocket change this is
200 000 pounds that we could have spent
on something for local residents uh so
i'd like to pass this motion um and i'd
also like to hear what people think
about this and ways we can take it
forward thank you
thank you do you have a second day
that's council windley
yeah i'll second and reserve the right
to speak later
thank you so
debate then council cornwell
thank you i'm i'm going to be sporting
this motion um section
1061 monies seems to be something that
seriously needs to be looked at
um in north wingfield we had a
development of 550 houses built
the serious impact was on homewood
itself
but not one penny of the set the money
that would go to a parish council will
come to hoop and homewood it will all go
to north wingfield and yet all the
effect is on homewood but the real
reason i'm speaking on this development
is that there's a mace field avenue
development by gleasons now for some
reason the monies went to county instead
of district
and for several years i've been asking
why has the money not come to district
it was accidentally given to county and
has still not come back to district and
north and ethan homewood have still not
seen that money so i'm asking council to
put that question in to find out where
our money
thank
is
council council renwick
yeah i am thank you councillor shipman
um for raising a valid um topic um i
think those who have been planning
meetings recently are aware that this is
an issue that quite a number of people
raised
um particularly in ridgeway i have been
asking about this issue for
i think under three years now um
i can't support your motion simply
because there's no point in chasing
people in liquidation and i don't think
the secretary of state is going to give
the answer you need i would much prefer
to try and find a way around this
internally because i'm not getting the
answers internally which i think is
where we need to start so i you know
thank you for raising it is important
but i don't think you've got the right
motion to to get the answers you need
council cupid
sorry chef okay thank you for raising
this important issue i think it is an
important debate to have and i'm sure
all members and residents will agree
that money to fund infrastructure
improvements in our district is
incredibly important so i do welcome the
opportunity to debate it and i take on
board what you've just mentioned council
cornwall and if you'd like to raise that
with me happy to take it up from a
district perspective
whilst i completely support what i think
of the underlying aims of the motion and
i hope we all do i can't support the
wording of the motion as i think it
misses the point misunderstands some of
the basic facts and doesn't achieve
anything similar to what counselor renix
just said as a first point both of these
examples date back to the previous
administration and the terms of the
section 106 agreements at the time and
so a legacy issue we've been trying to
solve and prevent
we recognize this issue and along with
councillor foster as his cabinet
portfolio we've been working to put new
systems in place both from a tighter
agreement council right
both from a tighter agreement's
perspective and from a monitoring angle
in indeed there's an irony that you've
probably only picked up on these
examples because of the improvements
councillor foster has led on and i'm
really grateful to him for those and
i'll let you cover in that in more
detail to look at the specific cases
mentioned in this motion which i've been
discussing with the actual local members
concerned for quite a while for one of
them your motion is factually incorrect
in stating the companies in liquidation
but it's still subject to legal action
so i can't go into that further but to
take the morton one they still need to
go for a formal committee or cabinet
decision but the key point to highlight
is that we can still recover that money
but it would be from the residents who
are now reliable as landowners
which without predetermining myself from
a future vote on the way forward with it
is a significant concern so you need to
consider the consequences of what you're
requesting here
as a final point this motion is asking
us to write to the secretary of state
and it's the debate that several members
have just raised about the general
system
to ensure that residents to ensure that
developers and directors are forced to
pay section 106 agreements i can clarify
this is already the case which is why we
are able to take legal and enforcement
action and liquidation issues are in
relation to the legal system rather than
government policy so developers are
already obliged to pay section 106s so
i'd argue it's the wider infrastructure
contribution system that needs reform
which is what this government has
committed to doing and indeed this
administration has already written to
the government to raise this exact issue
as part of our response on the planning
white paper consultation
to quote from the letter councillor dale
and i sent in october 2020 we have
several local examples where development
companies have been dissolved without
the section 106 payments being made or
developments being left incomplete to
avoid section 106 payments or
infrastructure improvements
this is one of the biggest frustrations
to communities particularly with regards
to promises such as affordable housing
allocations which are often the biggest
casualty
consequently there should be a greater
earlier certainty on infrastructure
conditions and ensuring these are
delivered so i hope the government takes
note to that so in summary this motion
is several months too late and i'm
probably being generous though because
we sent the letter in october 2020 and
doesn't really touch the surface of the
work we've been doing or will continue
to do in this regard so i can't support
it but i want to reassure members and
residents that along with my
conservative colleagues will continue to
go for action rather than words on this
and we'll keep the chamber and
specifically buying committee updated
thank you chair
thank you council foster
yeah uh thank you chair uh yeah i'll
just go to the details of what we have
actually done on this uh yes the
recording and collection of one of six
monies uh could have been done better in
the past uh and when i was uh chair of
audit this is something i brought up uh
the committee looked at it we put a
range of improvements in place a new
traffic light system which makes it
clearer so it's a lot easier for the
planning committee to keep track of
payments
uh and clear demarcations and duties uh
for the planning legal departments to
bring these monies in so this works
already being done internally to chase
these up uh we're also monitoring it on
a more regular basis on planning at the
minute it's every quarter uh and
part of this i think is why council
shipments actually been able to bring
this up in the first place
uh and because it has it has been
brought to planning
but what i would say is there are other
people that are aware that this work
went on before when i was chair of audit
we did it for quite a while and i know
uh council of arkham showed uh i'm sure
he backed me up over there
now
i know i've mentioned this before she'll
have to forgive me but it was a year
till i saw you
on uh on the audit committee that's why
you don't know that this where it went
on and more recent to that the records
are there if you want to check them and
more recent to that uh we've now got uh
our chair uh councillor becker who's now
chair of audit at the last meeting it
was also brought up again now you might
have missed that as well so this these
discussions have been going on in
committee they're not just discussed
here at council or in the derbyshire
times it looks good in the derbyshire
times but it's a committee where the
work is actually done so these systems
are in place and that's why you've been
able to spot it
thank you
any other comments or questions
council market
sorry i wasn't going to going to speak
well since i've
been mentioned
yeah
you'll write your lesson there don't we
uh
well yeah we are looking at that i mean
we we looked at this in prior to the
meeting and thought well i don't see
anything wrong with this it's it's going
to uh
it's just writing a letter and it's
about really and i accept what you're
saying that you may have done it but
i i don't i don't see a problem with
doing it again it's it is about these
developers that that seem to get away
with it they build houses they go out of
business and then they set up with a
different name and it's that sort of
concept that that we need to to sort of
challenge i think so
uh i think we'll carry on and vote for
it but that's the way we are with that
and i accept what the way it might that
that we've been done in audit and you
thank you councilman you've mentioned my
name so i better speak i don't know
any other comments or questions
council hancock
thank you chair yes i think actually
just to just reset because it is
anything is a process of continuous
improvement isn't it we can always keep
building on it it is good the process
the progress that we've made and
obviously we don't want to ever get rest
on our laws with that because there's
always things we can do um as as nigel's
actually just said the the key crux of
this is to actually
it is writing a letter and and we do see
it and i mean i used to be a mortgage
underwriter you know exactly what
happens with these companies they said
15 different subsidiaries and then they
send one bust as they go along we've all
seen it happen and we'll see it happen
again again so we do kind of need action
above our pay grade so it is purely
asking if we can get something there i
don't see another writer a letter would
hurt at all and that's all it's actually
asking for thank you chair
thank you
council windley you reserved your right
to say anything
you want to now
thank you right
then it's with you council shipment to
respond
thank you chair and then i i will thank
council foster for the work that he has
done in nordic committee to actually
bring forward some of the monetary
aspects of this but this goes beyond
monitoring that's the point i'm trying
to make here because it's all well and
good monitoring and seeing when
how much the oh yeah but when they go
bust and there's nothing to actually
claw that money back from then what
position you're left in that's the angle
that this motion motion's actually going
at because it's not just the monitoring
which is obviously good because you can
see kind of the train coming towards you
but it's what are we going to do as a
council to stop this happening again
because obviously we've had the policies
adopted from order that you've that
you've created council foster but the
situation has arisen
even with that in place
so clearly that's not enough and i think
we need to kind of look at ourselves and
what can we do better
if we can't do it better to stop this if
the issue arising who do we need to get
to do something to stop it and as far as
i can see
there's nothing that the district
council can do itself which can stop a
company going bust but like has been
mentioned i forgot to mention it was
another country mentioned it that
if we can hold the businesses or the
directors of those businesses to account
after they go bust
then potentially there is a means to
claw that money back but that's
something that will have to be done by
government and i don't see an issue with
writing a letter and explaining this
conundrum that we're in under the
district council to try and make that
situation better and hopefully we can
make sure we have that 200 000 pounds
return to us at some point
thank you so the motion's been proposed
and seconded so we now move to the vote
all those in favor of the motion please
show your hands
all those against
in the abstentions
that's it then the vote has been lost so
the motion thank you i'm just going to
take item 12 and then we can exclude the
public and then have a quick comfort
break
at that point so item 12 i move that the
public be excluded from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
item of business to avoid the disclosure
to them with exempt information as
defined in paragraphs one two and three
part one of schedule 12 a the local
government act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006 do you have a seconder
thank you councillor ruff hopefully
thank you
all those of you in favor
you know and against
the abstentions
thank you the public has it still thank
you for joining us today thank you
um so we'll have a comfort break of five
minutes so that i don't think we're
going to die of kobe we're all going to
have pneumonia
you